remember I told you before with that
sort of sort of Venn diagram that I
wasn't going to fill out that entire
diagram I'm not gonna fill out this
either there's multiple ways to
determine the nature of a stationary
point so it's not to overwhelm you and
make your brains explode I'm just going
to show you the most basic one and then
we're going to develop later from there
okay so to determine the nature of a
stationary point I'm going to use this
first derivative and I'm going to look
in between so what I'm gonna do is
construct a table this table is going to
have a bunch of X values compared with
the derivative at those X values so here
are my X values here are my derivatives
at those X values and in this case
you'll see why I pick this in a second
I'm going to need one two three four
five spots to be able to test this so
I'm gonna have a nice long or wide I
guess there's a better way to say it
table like this and over here I need
space for five individual slots so I'm
going to go one two there we go okay so
to determine the nature of these
stationary points I've constructed this
table and what I'm gonna do is choose
some values that sort of interleaved
between these points that I've already
got over here so see how negative one
and one very conveniently I'm nice and
evenly spaced out I wanna test to the
left and to the right of each one so
give me a value to the left of negative
one negative two will do the job
there's to the left then I get negative
one give me a value to the right of
negative one zero and then the next
stationary point and two looks like
it'll fit that's really convenient it
doesn't always line up so nicely okay
now what I want to do is for each of
these X values I want to find out the
corresponding derivative I already know
two of these numbers because I worked
them out over on the right hand side of
the board which numbers do I know for
negative one I know that this value is
going to be
zero that was the point of finding
narrative1 right and it's the same with
this guy it's zero okay so now it's up
to me to fill in the rest of this and
then try and form a picture okay so when
X is negative two
what is the derivative equal to well
here's the derivative here it is okay so
when you put negative two into this what
do you get 3 times 4 which is 12 minus 3
which is 9
there we go I've got a number when the
derivative is 0 I just get negative 3
and then lastly when the derivative
sorry when the x value is 2 I'm gonna
get 3 times 4 which is 12 again minus 3
again which is 9
okay so what we're going to do now is
call upon that knowledge who developed
on Wednesday about increasing and
decreasing okay so see how you've got a
positive value here what does that tell
you about whether it's going up or down
it's going up so I'm going to draw it
underneath here a line that's going up
it's going up right when you've got a
derivative that's zero here that means
you're not going up you're not going
down you're going just straight across
like that
does that make sense negative number
what's the function doing it's
decreasing and then it's zero and that
is increasing your game
okay so you can see in very rough form
what I've traced out here is the shape
of well what's the original function
it's a cubic right so therefore I know
look see this is where the cubic does
sort of this thing right whereas over
here this is where the cubic kind of
goes like that okay so the point I'm
interested in negative 1 and positive 1
for the X values one of them is a
maximum and one of them is a minimum
which ones which that's the max you see
it's at the top and this is the minimum
you see it's at the bottom okay so I
would say therefore what my coordinates
again negative 1/9 is a maximum turning
point because you can see now I've
established it turns before I had all
this information I didn't know look back
at your Venn diagram I didn't know if it
was going to go up then stop and then
keep on going up it didn't have to turn
right let me just finish writing this
Eric and then I'll come to your question
and what was my other thing it was one
come to five
okay Eric you had your hand up a second
ago do you have a question you could
graph it
do you graph it yeah you should yeah
okay so remember I said to you before
there are many different ways to do for
example what we're doing right now oh
this is one of them
this is the basic method in some ways
it's a bit like the first principles of
our stationary points the first
principles that words in there this is
what you would always go back to this
will always work this will always give
you a picture later on we're gonna learn
some other fancier methods they might be
faster but they're not always as useful
like for example you could do that
because you know what this looks like
but I can easily give you a function
that you go like I have no idea what
that looks like so I've got to work out
the pieces okay all right now how's your
brain going does that make sense we know
how to find these stationary points we
also know how to work out what kind of
stationary points they are to follow up
questions to follow up questions in this
case we found a maximum and a minimum
but we also know bless you that you can
get these horizontal points of
inflection now what kind of information
would we see in this table that would
lead us to conclude not a max nanami
it's a horizontal point of inflection
what kind of numbers would you expect
think about it you can go back to the
picture that you drew if you're lying
okay so so this is about the gradients
in their values right so Dhruv is
exactly on the mark what happens if
there's a horizontal point of inflection
it goes up it goes across what makes
this a maximum is it comes back down
right but what if it didn't come back
down what if it's decided you know what
I'm gonna having my break I'm gonna go
back up right what if this was positive
three not negative three have a look at
this now see this that is clearly not a
maximum it's not a minimum either that
is this shape that we were talking about
that's a horizontal point of inflection
you see so you have to read these
numbers interpret what's happening
geometrically and then think of the
picture that matches does that make
sense
so that would lead to a different
conclusion okay second follow-up
question what does maximum mean that's
not a rhetorical question well if
someone said the maximum temperature
today is 23 degrees I think that's what
they said is it what does that mean and
these it's the highest it can go the
highest it can go except you should be
troubled by that because that is clearly
not the highest that this function can
go right like look I've even drawn a
little bit up here this is clearly
higher than this right so in what sense
is this the maximum grab another color
if you can and we can qualify what's
going on this is all fine but we could
be a little more accurate we can say
that negative 1/9 is a relative maximum
what that means is it's the maximum
relative to what's going on nearby does
that make sense
like it's the highest spot in this
little area the way we say this is okay
well what's the who's the tallest person
in this class these are the tallest
person just class and it you know we
might say I might say today or we might
say I could whoever we want right we say
okay we've established they're the
tallest person in this class that's
relative to everyone in this room but
that's different to saying that's the
tallest person on the planet or in
history or something like that right so
what would be the opposite of a word
like relative what word would you choose
that MIT actually no this is the tallest
the maxima get
anywhere the opposite you would choose
is usually the word put this in a
different color because on this case
it's not true whoops
the opposite is absolute okay
now you may sometimes here are the
language applied to this some
geographical language in fact okay so
some people don't say this is a relative
max some people would say this is a
local max local as in like in this
locality
right the opposite of local is global
everywhere like considering everyone so
you can sometimes hear it is called
local versus global I prefer relative
and absolute okay